hey happy Wednesday welcome back to PE
daily again no I am not PE my name is
Christine Grace and I'll be hosting PE
daily again today PE is still in Miami
as I'm sure you've all seen so make sure
you're keeping up to date with all of
her content in London we are business as
usual so I'm going to be covering this
week's treachery debauchery all of the
nonsense going on in society I have a
very special guest with me today
everyone please welcome nazarin
hi nazarin is helping me out today and
she's also going to be giving her
thoughts on the treachery debauchery
going on in society today so yeah let's
get straight into it today the first
topic on today's agenda is the Logan
Paul Dyan danis fight now me and our
lovely producer King we're actually at
this fight so make sure you go check out
my Channel at Christine gra Smith um for
all of the latest footage covering the
fight but yeah it was a really great
experience and I'm sure you've all seen
the clips so yeah let's roll the clip
[Music]
[Applause]
this could get really guys there's a lot
of
bad what the heck so yeah I mean as I
said me and King were actually at the
fight so we saw this all unfold in
person and it kind of just happened
really really quickly like the fight
pretty much ended and then next thing
you know it to me it seemed like Dylan
was just fuming with the situation and
then took everything too far and stepped
outside of boxing and tried to like
tackle him down to the floor next thing
you know there's like one security guard
and then as you saw like the whole thing
is just completely flooded I've been
told what he was attempting to do was a
gutin so to me it just L like he was
trying to rush him yeah well I don't
know anything about boxing but it
doesn't really look like a boxing match
said look so yeah no it's definitely not
boxing I think at the end of the day
Dylan was talking a lot of [__] before
the fight he was antagonizing Logan PA
about his fiance and it was really
entertaining but I think because he
didn't really do much in the fight maybe
he just thought he'd provide us with one
last bit of entertainment I don't know
watching a school classroom fight yeah
yeah when there's like a fight teachers
come in everyone floods over everyone
crowds over that is it literally but to
be fair I I will say from actually
seeing the fight myself Logan was
dominating Logan was throwing the
majority of punches however Logan's a
fairly big dude from the punches and
everything that he was actually throwing
I would have thought Dylan would have
got knocked out so the fact that Dylan
was still standing I'd have to give him
props for that and Hey look yeah Connor
McGregor said that he was impressed by
Dylan's performance now whether he's
talking about his boxing or not I don't
know he could just be talking about the
fact that he's an Entertainer he
definitely put on a good show with all
of the buildup the the song he came out
to was uh free from desire as well so he
really got all of the British crowd up
and jumping so he's definitely an
Entertainer a boxer I don't know I don't
know anything about boxing either so you
guys can can let me know in the comments
what you thought on that because I just
thought the whole thing was a bit of a
mess but hey here we are looks like
other people did as well yeah I don't
think I've seen too many people actually
happy with the fight it was pretty
disappointing I think when you have
something that has so much buildup so
much tension you're hoping to see
someone get knocked out obviously yeah
you expect a bit more from it yeah no
one did so here we are so this is a a
comment from from someone regarding the
fight all that talk for the fight to be
like this yeah I I completely agree it
was uh bit boring actually a dark day
for boxing we need the greats to come
back and get rid of these Social
Butterflies anyone can tell this was
some bad acting and script terrible it
does look scripted to be honest it looks
like actors um in a TV show I was saying
this to King the whole time I was saying
I can guarantee that when it gets to the
main fights it's going to be pretty
bland they've probably got in their
contracts how many punches they can each
throw especially when you look at the
production level as well for example KSI
came out in a Lamborghini cuz you know
he's got that song Lamborghini he's got
a song called Lamborghini he came out in
an actual Lamborghini oh to that song
and then he bought out gigs as well so
the amount of money that's gone into
this you know I just I definitely think
it was a a performance um rather than
yeah the other fights however um as I
said go go check out my channel to to
see the footage were really entertaining
and they were what seemed like to me at
least someone who doesn't know a thing
about boxing really good fights and we
did see yeah we saw near enough a
knockout I don't know if it actually
classes as a knockout but to me it
seemed like a knockout yeah uh someone
else says Dylan tweeted more than
punches he
threw it's true I think he probably only
threw like three
punches so yeah that's as it stands you
know the the fight was pretty boring
again I just think when you have all of
that hype and all of the beef that was
going on beforehand you you're hoping to
see some kind of spectacular display but
we just we didn't see that and it was
rather anticlimactic maybe that's why we
saw the brawl at the end maybe that's
what that was for to kind of satisfy
people give them something but aren't
celebrity fights usually more staged and
not really like they don't live up to
their expectations I mean from what I've
seen yeah I don't know if that's like an
actual thing but I it wouldn't surpris
me if that was like well in their
contracts it's it's a show rather than
an actual boxing match but I think so
there we are there we have it moving on
to the next topic today we're going to
be taking a look at a video of a woman
who she basically got taken on a date by
a guy and he bought her to the
Cheesecake Factory which is I think is
like a I don't know if they actually do
cheesecake but I think it's like a
Fridays type cheesecake as well yeah
that's what I've heard anyway it's a
restaurant nonetheless and this lady got
taken to this restaurant and she is very
unhappy with her situation right even
though she's on a date and you you would
think it would be ladylike and polite to
just be happy to be on the date MH but
uh she seems to have a a different idea
let's let's take a
look all right let me just get the door
for you
okay okay rest you want to talk about it
I so you expect a man to go all out on
the first day is that right I mean
you're supposed to look at I
mean
wow yeah speechless at that it's just
the entitlement you know she she's she's
admitting to to everything that she did
wrong and she's saying that she's not
ready for him to come up to her
apartment so he says okay fine if we're
if we're not ready for that then maybe
you're not ready for me to Splash all my
money out on a fancy date and I think
that's fair enough yeah I think I
understand what she's saying on a first
date you don't want someone don't want
me anyway I would sort of feel a bit
uncomfortable having a man come into my
place because obviously you know it
leads to things and but be on time then
cuz he's saying he was waiting for her
for a whole hour so be on time you if
you don't want him coming inside your
flat be on time be downstairs at the
right time that you both agreed to be
there for and you know go on a date
don't keep him waiting around because
then yeah he's not going to take you to
a fancy restaurant he's going to take
you to the Cheesecake Factory and also
I'm sorry but have you did you see what
are you thinking what I'm thinking she's
saying she's doing everything that she
should be doing for a woman and she's
basically acting like she's a 10 yeah
and she's very clearly not a I mean she
was like does it look like I belong in
the Cheesecake Factory yes kind of yeah
you look like pretty much any other girl
like you're you're nothing special and
from what I know of the Cheesecake
Factory it's just a normal restaurant
I'm trying to think of what the
equivalent is over here maybe like
Harvester or like I have never heard
you've never heard of harvester I don't
know have you heard like Lola's cupcakes
sure even Lola's cupcakes I think that's
a bit expensive I
know but I mean we can both agree she is
acting like she is the type of woman
that
is we're talking a nine a 10 a model
she's just not and I think something
really important to note here is this
woman is not interested in in this man
not even remotely yeah you can tell
because if she was interested in him he
could have taken her anywhere okay women
when they are interested in a man it
doesn't matter where you are you're just
grateful to be around him I remember
when me and my boyfriend first died
dating he he made a joke once and he was
like uh I'm taking you to the Golden
Archers and I thought oh my God that
sounds so like fancy I I'd never heard
this joke before I'd never heard
McDonald's be referred to as the Golden
Archers so I was like wow like what's
the Golden Archers um and we turned up
at McDonald's and when he said it I was
kind of thinking like I'm not dressed
for a Golden Archers type place like
what is this place and then we T up at
McDonald's and Not only was I relieved
because I thought you know I am not
dressed for a fancy place but you were
happy it didn't matter because I was
just happy to be with him yeah it wasn't
about where we was going and any girl
who's actually interested in a guy it
doesn't matter where you are it doesn't
matter what you're doing it could be a
walk in the park it could be a coffee it
could literally be anything you're just
happy to be around them so you know I
think this guy has dodged a bullet here
definitely she was using him she's of
course she's using him and she probably
does this to to many guys yeah and you
can tell just from her entit entitlement
and her attitude the type of woman she
is but uh yeah these These are what the
comments are saying he should have just
taken her to a factory forget the
cheesecake
part get her doing some hard labor with
that dollhouse mindset it's true
completely agree I'd love to watch that
so would I part
two another one says she looks dressed
for McDonald's she's
lucky
yeah yeah she looks dressed like she's
going to The Cheesecake Factory she does
though that's what I said like you know
it's nothing special she doesn't look
dressed up um so I'm a bit confused as
to why she thinks that she belongs in a
fancy restaurant when she doesn't even
and this is what we're doing to women is
that we're telling all women you can be
a 10 we're telling all women Beauty has
nothing to do with about we're telling
all women Beauty has nothing to do with
how you look beauty is a feeling and as
long as you can emulate that feeling of
empowerment and self-love and confidence
then that somehow equates to how you
look on the outside but the reality is
you look how you look it's good if you
are happy within your own skin I I would
never wish for anyone to be
uncomfortable in their own skin but you
look how you look and that is a fact and
you just have to accept your
circumstances for what they are be great
ful that you are in the position that
you are cuz let's not forget you know
you might not be the prettiest person in
the world but not everyone can use their
arms and legs you know exactly yeah
there's always going to be someone worse
than you and we've seemed to have fallen
prey to this mindset of of teaching
girls that we're on a pedestal and that
all men have to kind of flock and climb
on top of each other to try we want yeah
and it it expects nothing of the women
which is completely unfair to the men
and I actually feel really bad for this
guy cuz he's he's waited around an hour
for her he's bought her somewhere and he
even got out of the car to open the door
for her yeah oh I didn't even see that
he got out of the car he says do you
want me to open the door for you but she
had locked the door to his car yeah
that's crazy you can tell he's so
genuine and she's just like deluded but
she looks like mentally ill I don't know
it's kind there's kind of something
weird there the way she's filming
herself the entire time and making faces
like she's a celebrity yeah it's really
like I think she's deluded in more ways
than one like she thinks she's better
than than she is as well which is also a
delusion I think what's scary is the
fact that she's not a rare type of woman
I think what's scary is the fact that
there's probably loads of these videos
out there this just happens to be one
that's that's blown up there we go
moving swiftly on topic number three on
today's agenda we have a video of a man
calling his friend to tell him that his
girl is no longer his girlfriend I
actually haven't seen this clip so yeah
let's check it
out Tiffany's no longer my
girlfriend hey god dude that woman was
the craziest person I've ever met in my
life oh hold up hold up hold up she's
actually we're engaged now she's my
fiance it's she's no longer my
girlfriend she's my fiance what the hell
Mike I am so sorry that she's your
fiance oh my
God that's so awkward I have seen that
clip I I actually have seen that clip
before that is really
awkward um I don't even know what to say
I think surely he should have spoke to
the people around him before making a
life-changing decision like proposing to
someone I think it's kind of worrying
that he's called his friend and his
friend isn't already aware of the
situation um and I think if his friend
was aware of the situation at least it
seems like to me if this man had any
sense about him if he had his head
screwed on properly he probably wouldn't
be calling to say that she's my fiance
because he would have already had the
conversation of I'm thinking of getting
engaged to her and his friend would have
communic C look I don't think she's good
for you I think she's headache yeah in
which case if he was in a good mindset
he would trust the people around him and
perhaps not have proposed I mean the
fact she said she's the craziest girl
he's ever met in his life it kind of um
makes you think why like what what's she
done but it could be also a fake video
it could be it could be because I if if
my friends had expressed that they feel
that way about my partner and then I
went against their judgment and you know
did something they told me not to I
probably wouldn't record myself with my
partner next to me telling my friend
that I know doesn't approve of my
partner yeah I think if it is real at
least I mean it's the internet we can
never really know for sure these days
but if it is real I think
unfortunately a lot of people especially
in our generation they don't speak to
their friends and family and people
around them who they should trust about
life decisions true they just kind of
take things into their own hands I think
we live in a very individualistic
culture at the moment I think everything
has become very selfish and everyone has
this idea that they know best um you
know we had that trend of calling older
people Boomers and you know when when an
older person said something it was okay
Boomer you know which is you know funny
we can all laugh about it this was
during the time of Vine I I happened to
love Vine and thought it was hilarious
but the point is is that actually you're
never going to get anywhere in life
unless you accept and understand that
there are always going to be people who
have been around longer than you MH so
therefore they probably know something
you don't and it's why it's really
important who you surround yourself with
because it's better to have two people
in your corner who you you trust their
opinion no matter what and you know that
they've got their your best interests at
heart and 20 people around you who
actually don't care about what you do
with your life and I can guarantee you
if he did tell anyone that he was going
to propose to this woman they were
probably very bad friends because they
probably didn't give the right kind of
advice and just said oh amazing I'm so
happy for you you're going to get
married you know a lot of people don't
give their true feelings because again
we live in a very soft culture where
people scar offending people scared of
offending people exactly one of the
comments says she thought her past was
behind her yeah I mean we don't know the
situation there makes you wonder is
Mike's friend settling or is Mike just
hating I got to know something better
call Bro by the side putting calls on
loudspeaker is definitely not my thing
anything could pop out true but also if
you have to live your life like that
that just indicates to me you're
surrounding yourself with the wrong
people you have to hide everything from
everyone you know you know you probably
you should probably take a look at that
yeah if I were him I wouldn't have done
that like I said as me I wouldn't be
afraid to do that because I don't I know
that I don't have anything to hide I
know that you know people I surround
myself truly have my best interests at
her can't relate to him no can't relate
but I think unfortunately there's
a lot of people who who can and and
that's a real shame that that's where
we're at in our culture and something
needs to change guys start surrounding
yourself with better people and speak to
your friends and family about what they
think about your partner because yes
they're going to be biased because they
care about you you know a little bit of
bias is kind of good in that scenario
cuz they're probably going to tell you
the truth and if they're all saying bad
things well you should probably look at
your circumstances and maybe make a
change or don't you have the freedom to
live your life as you wish what do I
know but I'm just I'm just trying to
help like a
therapist moving on so I'm sure you've
heard of the whole Jaya Smith and yes
I've heard of small things but I don't
really know the full story neither do I
I don't think anyone does I actually saw
a meme the other day um someone sent me
a meme and it was like a Jada Smith says
she's actually never met Will Smith um
which really tickled me because uh it
wouldn't surprise me if that hit the
news the next day but from what I know
that whole thing happened with Will
Smith punched him Chris Rock and kind of
since then I think all of this stuff has
come out about their relationship a lot
of people on the internet are calling
Will Smith a simp and it does seem like
he's really trying his best to make this
relationship work and she just seems to
be this kind of tyrannical dictator
that's standing above him and just
keeping him very much at a distance um
but yeah we have a video of Jada Smith
in an interview um discussing this
relationship so let's take a look if you
find another great love or If Will finds
another great love there's no finding
another great love and I think that's
the point it's like we are in a place
now that we are in a deep healing space
and we are really concentrating on
healing the relationship between us so
it may not be the divorce on paper
anymore there's no divorce on paper I
mean not on paper there might not be a
divorce in theory anymore yeah no we
really have been working hard oh okay
well I didn't know I was trying to well
I totally missed that on the H the whole
thing so wait so wait just so I'm 100%
clear you were divorced not on paper but
now we might be a point where we're back
together we are working very hard at
bringing our relation yes bringing our
relationship to together back to a
marriage again back to a life
partnership yes because here's the thing
about husband wife marriage for me for
my healing process I came into that with
very specific ideas very specific ideas
that were blocks to me just seeing will
as who he is he can't be this perfect
idealized husband I have to be able to
accept him for the human that he is he
accepts me for the human that I am and
we want to love each other there okay so
you might like live in the same house
and have the yeah okay poor will and
those poor
kids I just really want to point out how
uh she's all about her and her
expectations of the marriage and it
seems like she's indicating that he fell
short of her expectations um but she
doesn't seem to have any concern for
what his expectations were and maybe not
to be cheated on y exactly cuz I heard
she's been around yeah I I think that's
true and it wouldn't really surprise me
just going off of off of this it
wouldn't surprise me if she's the kind
of woman that's been around CU she
definitely seems like the kind of woman
that is not hair bonded to her partner
so that would suggest that she's been
around a block a few times but I I
really have a problem with people who
air out their dirty laundry I really
really don't like it when people as I
said they air out their dirty laundry
they they put all of their problems in
the public eye um I just think it's bad
taste I think it's t it makes me cringe
um and even if someone close to me did
it I would just have to act like I
didn't see it because I'm not going to
get involved on that I'm not going to
jump on the bandwagon of say a friend
post something about her boyfriend she's
slagging him off or whatever I'm not
going to then jump on that bandwagon and
pop up and be like can't believe he did
this cuz you're just fueling the fire um
and really relationship problems should
be within the relationship it should be
the the couple versus the problem and
especially in a marriage because you
know that's the whole thing the sanctity
of marriage it's between two people and
all problems should be resolved between
you two within the context of that yeah
and sometimes when you actually go to
other people and go against your partner
or husband in this case it can actually
have a bad effect because some people
don't have your best interests at heart
and then they can advise you the wrong
things and lead you to do to make bad
decisions and ruin your marriage so
definitely not um the right way to go
about it I mean I agree with what she's
saying about you know you can't have
unrealistic expectations of your husband
and you need to love him for who he is
because you know in a marriage you're
both Sinners you're both you're not
perfect no one's perfect we're all
imperfect so you have to accept that but
you know she hasn't actually treated her
marriage with that with that same
attitude because you're if you believe
that you shouldn't be cheating on your
partner I don't understand that like a
marriage isn't for that yeah I mean I
think it's all very hypocritical and I
think it's really important what you
said you know when you take problems
outside of the relationship you you're
really running a real risk because the
truth is not everyone does have your
best interests at heart and I think
especially with the fact that what we're
seeing is the the half of this
relationship that is outsourcing the
problems is is the female he and I think
it's especially dangerous in this day
and age when women go to their friends
about relationship problems because the
truth is we've we've seen already with
the other topics on on today's agenda
you know a lot of women out there are
messed up right now they've been fed so
much [__] by the mainstream media by
social media um even with the way that
we're raising kids today a lot of women
actually don't like it when their friend
is in a relationship especially if
they're part of today's culture of
things like going out clubbing and
everything's for the Instagram pictures
they don't want their friends to be in a
relationship because that means oh well
I'm I'm I'm not going to be able to go
out and get drunk with you as much of
course going to encourage you to bin off
a relationship because they they don't
actually care about your happiness they
care about what you mean in relation to
them yeah so yeah I think that's a
really important Point jealousy exactly
as well they they want it they pretend
they don't want it but they do want it
because they know they can see how happy
you are and they don't seem to
understand that because maybe they've
never had that before yeah so they try
and discourage you from um pursuing
something meaningful yeah um and they
try and make you trade it for something
which is you know less meaningful
definitely because they know that they
can't attain that for themselves but I
know there's a there's a continuation
from this interview so so let's see what
else it has so in the comments we've got
their relationship sounds like a trauma
Bond oh this term this term is driving
me nuts I like to say that trauma Bond
uh is um the excuse that people use for
being with someone who doesn't make them
happy I've never heard of this before so
a trauma bond is this idea that uh so
say you get with a gentleman and this
gentleman starts breaking your heart
maybe you unfortunately go through some
kind of abuse it's not working the
relationship is dysfunctional the idea
of a trauma bond is that the reason you
stay is because psychologically you're
kind of addicted to the stress of it so
it's this whole idea of like chasing the
highs and lows the roller coaster of a
relationship and how you know movies and
everything would tell young girls to go
after the toxic guy because that's where
the roller coaster is yeah um more
exciting yeah but you know and we've
told kids that having a healthy
relationship is boring and that it's
better to have a toxic relationship
because at least then it's thrilling but
yeah I think it's just an excuse trauma
bond is just a way to go I don't like my
circumstances but I'm too addicted to it
to change them I actually used to
believe that myself um but I've woken up
to that as well and I now know that you
can always remove yourself from
something like if you always have that
choice like you're you're in complete
control of your actions and yeah making
excuses isn't going to get you out of
anything and it's just going to make you
more unhappy and yeah to don't agree
with that I'm not even denying the
psychology behind it because you know
when you look at things like addiction
why do people get addicted it is because
of things like a release of oxytocin a
release of dopamine and I think when you
are in a toxic relationship that
definitely can be the case that you kind
of get maybe it's similar to addiction
maybe it is an addiction but you can
very you can very much get lost in the
OR deal of it all you can get lost in
the roller Coter addicted to the good
parts and you keep wanting the good
parts to come and you chase the highs
yeah no matter how low the lows are
however like you
say whether or not we can always set
ourselves free you know because some
people may argue well what about
crackheads and heroin addicts you
know I just think it's better to at
least perhaps it's delusional but if you
can tell yourself that no matter what
you can always change your circumstances
chances are you're going to be better
off in life because even when the odds
are completely against you if you have
that mindset of I can always change my
circumstances you're going to try harder
to do that so it's just a a better
mindset to have in general but yeah
another comment says I saw a Tik Tok of
a therapist who dissects how
narcissistic people speak and how they
speak on both sides so that they are
never wrong right or can be caught in a
lie I dismissed the Tik Tok until I saw
this video she is choosing her
words so very delicately so very
delicately yeah I can kind of see that
she just looks a bit Psychopathic I mean
I just think it's you're obviously
chasing something if you have to
constantly go on TV and talk about your
relationship and she she just constantly
seems to be slandering will like it just
seems like all the time she's just
[__] on him and sometimes she
disguises it as she's trying to say oh
we're like this one we we're healing and
we're working together it's like but
don't act like you haven't done all of
these other interviews previously where
you've been making him look like a weak
man like you've really damaged his
reputation paent but it probably helps
her because then she feels stronger she
feels stronger you can tell she's very
masculine like yeah the way that she
presents herself the way that she speaks
the way that she talks even you can tell
that she has full control in that
relationship and he's just like
hopelessly in love with her and like
trailing behind her like a little
dog um and yeah sadly he hasn't realize
that he can break himself free from that
but 100% agree with you I do also think
that because of marage and like the S
sanctity of it I do believe that you
know once you marry someone you've made
that choice and I think will is keeping
yeah I think will is keeping his side of
the agreement um um I I don't know if
Will is a religious man but maybe that
comes into it maybe that's why probably
isn't I mean I don't know think they're
quite the opposite of religious I think
they yeah worship something
[Laughter]
else got to do an episode on that
because yeah I I agree with you there
but look something's keeping him there
whether it be you know the sanctity of
marriage or maybe just pure
embarrassment something's keeping him
around and I can't help but feel bad for
the guy perhaps that's because I'm a
woman so I'm empathetic and emotional
about it I'm sure a lot of guys would
sit here and say he needs to leave her
um and I agree but I can't help but feel
bad for him because he's just like you
say trading along like a a lost puppy
another comment says why is she always
speaking in riddles and avoiding the
truth in tal working hard to bring our
relationship together divorced but not
divorced I'm tired honestly she reminds
me of
[Laughter]
Boris we're on YouTube so we'll say no
more but if you know what I mean you
know what I mean I know what you mean we
always do this at the end of Po daily um
there is a surprise Reddit story um we
were just having a conversation before
the show nazarin didn't know what Reddit
is so I think I've now got you up to
date yeah it's just a forum people tell
their stories and uh yeah we get to read
those stories so let's take a look my
boyfriend and I have been dating for
over a decade and I genuinely love him
he is the nicest person I know but due
to some differences between US during
the past few months I used sex with
other people as an outlet and cheated on
him he found out and broke up with me
and I fully understand and respect his
decision I'm seriously not this type of
person and I am a good human being I
just happen to do something bad his
mother and I have been close for a long
time she absolutely adores me and I love
her too we have a very close
relationship she has taught me how to
knit and I have taught her how to make
presentations and stuff we Bond really
well we are really close and I asked my
ex if he could hide my cheating it is
something between me and him and no one
else needs to know about it thankfully
he agreed and told his mom that we had
an amicable breakup up due to Mutual
differences I still visit his mom at
times and he ignores me which hurts a
lot but he is friendly enough at times
and even Smiles at me when I'm around
his mother I explained to my friend the
complex situation I'm in and she told me
that I'm being an [__] by letting my
ex not have any room to vent since he
has told everyone that it was an
amicable breakup and we are still
friends honestly it was a mutual
decision and he agreed to it so I do not
think I've done anything wrong when it
comes to keeping it between ourselves
would love a fresh perspective thanks
this is
crazy I feel like when someone really
needs to justify that they're a good
person are they're probably
not if you if you have to constantly say
I I promise I'm good mhm chances are
you've done a lot of stuff that would
suggest that you're not now we don't
know this lady really and truly this is
all we know but from this I I would not
class her as a good person um and I
actually think that she is surrounded by
amazing friends because the friends have
told her the truth the friends have said
you're being a dick yeah you've you've
put him in a position where he has to
lie to everyone about what's actually
happened he can't get the emotional
support that he probably needs during
this very distressing time and you're
being out of order and what a great
friend to tell her that because how many
friends in this day and age would
actually be that brutal and honest with
you usually it's like you go girl all
done for cheating whoever this girl is
you you've got an amazing friend the
friend who said this to you is a keep
her around
because that is a very good friend I'm
sorry this isn't an accident because it
wasn't just once I used sex with other
people people people what so it wasn't
an accident it's not a mistake like if
it just happened once I would be much
more um not I mean not understanding
because I still don't understand it but
I'd be a little bit more understanding
but the fact it's like multiple people I
just can't it's not an accident also
this whole thing is about her you know
that there is nothing about him so the
only thing that she actually mentions as
to why this happened um cuz I think we
all know like if a woman cheats chances
are that that's because something was
was going wrong for well down the line
and then she's instead of being an adult
about it and bringing it up she she's
gone and cheated on him because she's
not able to have a conversation about
things but you know she just seems to be
overcompensating for a lot he is the
nicest person I know but due to some
differences between US during the past
few months she doesn't then go to
clarify what those differences are she
doesn't tell us what's actually happened
she she wants a fresh perspective
actually what I think she wants is to be
reinforced that don't worry you're a
good person because she didn't get that
from the friend so now she's come on the
internet and add out her dirty laundry
gross because she wants someone online
to to do it for her instead of just
accepting no I messed up I've been awful
I'm very ashamed of myself I should
probably fix myself to make sure I don't
hurt someone like this in the future and
again the whole middle section is just
about her relationship with his mom
she's not even recognizing what her
friend is saying she's literally come
online and told the internet what her
friend is saying and she can't even say
you know what I see I do see what she's
saying there's no acknowledgement or
responsibility here no but also if you
love him and you love his mom and you
love being around his family why did he
cheat on him because you
know I mean you would know that he's
going to a that to them and if you have
that much respect he hasn't even been
able to do that I know exactly but he
probably would have if she tell him not
to like it's so there's something not
right there she's put her own
relationship with a guy's
mother before his relationship also he's
not being strong enough to be like no
yeah you know I completely agree F off
you did this to me I'm now going to cut
you out of my life and my mom's life and
I'm going to tell her what you did
because you know people deserve to know
what you're really like why why why is
he even allowing her around his mom
knowing that she's got the capability to
hurt people like no that's very true
manipulate people that's very true no he
needs to completely get this girl out of
his life completely they're both in the
wrong yeah they are both in the wrong
it's just I guess my heart just goes out
to him because he's already been through
so much um but no you are completely
right he needs to completely Bend this
girl off and get her out of his life
just straight up tell the mom cuz I can
guarantee you the mom would not be
having this relationship with her she
knew what what actually happened so it's
almost like he's joining in on the
manipulating yeah he's almost hurting
himself further by allowing this to
happen and his mom because it's it's
ultimately a lie isn't it anyway we have
an edit on this story so she's come back
to give us all an update I feel like a
lot of you are calling me a bad person
because I cheated oh my God what people
are calling you a bad person cuz you
cheated how could you how could they if
my boyfriend broke up with me I think I
have suffered the
consequences I am a good person and I
try to be a better one each day it's
complicated I genuinely want opinions on
the mutual decision my boyfriend and I
made not to tell his mother I did beg
and plead but in the end it was an
agreement from both sides so I did use
my tactics of feminine manipulation
which we all know are the the tears and
the I'm just a weak frail little girl
that that doesn't know any better so not
only have I manipulated him into a
situation um but I'm also going to sit
here and say that it was
Mutual
what
look guy if you happen to come across
this and see us reading this story
please get rid of her please tell your
mom please tell your mom tell your mom
please tell your mom and she'll get rid
of her for you she will if you are not
in the position to be a man right now
that is what your mom is for yeah use
her it's just like I understand people
are flawed like yeah we sin we we make
mistakes but not multiple times like
it's multiple people she's cheated with
it's not that that's the thing me it's
everyone has come back and said that
she's a bad person and instead of
listening obvious to everyone this this
is how you know that that a lot of
modern women are narcissistic because if
loads of people are screaming something
at you chances are it's true it's true
so instead of coming back to edit and
try and justify again I'm still a good
person why are you all saying I'm not
maybe you should look and go oh [__]
maybe I [__] up
here but no the
delusion wins again yeah so much
delusion it's actually hard to it's hard
to live in this society when everyone's
just like it seems like everyone's crazy
but you sometimes yeah yeah and that's
why it's great to have you here in our
room because you remind me that there
are other people who are not
completely bewildered with delusion so
yeah what did you guys think of that why
don't you let us know in the comments
below um nazarin thank you so much for
for joining me here today um obviously
I'm I'm covering for pel so it's it's
always great to have someone else along
my by my side um where can people find
you um so I'm on Twitter and Instagram
um and YouTube as well but I don't
really use that as much but my username
is at Nazar and
Veronica yeah yeah go check her out
she's definitely got some interesting
things I'll say no more go check it out
for yourselves anyway um one final
announcement before we close out Today's
Show have you been feeling like you're
just not really getting much attention
from from women you know are you looking
to find a partner are you looking to get
some female attention well good news for
you cuz we have the ultimate babe magnet
we are offering women shouldn't vote
t-shirts get yourself your women
shouldn't vote t-shirts the ultimate
babe magnet cury of the audacity Network
store um the link is in the description
so you can get yours I guarantee you if
you wear this t-shirt in public women
will look at you you might even get some
come up to you and speak to you and
disclaimer I am not responsible for
anything they say to you on the basis of
seeing this t-shirt but they will
definitely look nonetheless so go get
your t-shirts now at the audacity
Network store the link is in the
description and yeah if you like my
coverage of pearl daily uh don't worry
she she's coming back I'm just here
covering while she's away and but go
check out my Channel at Christine gra
Smith and check out my series debunk in
the lunacy where I tell you the flip
side to things that the mainstream media
narrative doesn't necessarily want you
to know so if that sounds like something
that you'd be into definitely go check
it out and I'll see you over there take
care we'll see you next
time
[Music]